how's the Cobra - River and welcome to
backflip madness I'm playing it on the
iPad I got four Anna's been playing in
and she recommended I try it out so
let's do it
level two I mean level one yes
alright whoa whoa okay I'm glad I can do
that yes okay what holiday okay sure
so I can change switch flip I want to
make come on baby
score whatever let's try that ah come on
all right what about this come on don't
be a [ __ ] best flips ever how does that
even work I do it oh yes god I hate you
okay what about this there we go melanda
hey that [ __ ] whoa man edu Matney jab
like you mama cannula what can I do it
fine here why are you doing backflips
only I don't understand it said nothing
else you can do with your life like
[ __ ] skiing suing I don't even know
nice so [ __ ] close
Oh how did I get viola here is fantastic
how to hire here - honey okay this is
the most difficult one okay all right
everything is on this jump everything
nailed s what what am I supposed to go
where am I supposed to go ha ha
nailed it it's not the last one what am
I supposed to go ha ha ha I'm so
talented I'm such a PR challenge what
happened alright we unlocked prot 1
normal difficulty the other one was easy
you [ __ ] kidding me
no big deal I'm good at this oh [ __ ]
this [ __ ] high up double backflip of
just set [ __ ] naylet so good so good
alright what now what now but now okay
easy easy exactly what I wanted oh oh
suits NT ball get out at a high five
high five
thank you I know I don't know where to
go
probably I know that are you [ __ ] my
house ha ha ha ah don't you dag him over
me come on
Oh Danny Oh one man on a mission that
[ __ ] I mean back flip what do you do
with that bow
what do you the barrel saved my life who
would have thought oh ok one more one
more baby girl huh maybe you two feet
kook
don't you dare game over me [ __ ] oh why
he has to make so many goddamn backflips
one backflip fine
two backflips hey you know what maybe he
feels a little crate what that dad
looked at what what what was that
tell metell what are you going
all right we're gonna do this jump it's
not good man it's that no more clap it
up
yes that was a little awkward I felt
like you didn't really clap and it's
okay don't worry about it I heard my
hands level-3 [ __ ] poured two - oh good
because I that's what I really wanted in
another port with this same [ __ ]
music let's spice it up with some new
backflips what up [ __ ] what up [ __ ] ass
Medusa doom Yvette what the hell is that
what the [ __ ] is that
look at that [ __ ] Yolo this is Lilly
Yolo mode what the hell just get cut me
is some slack
I don't know what slack tastes like but
just cut it I'm not gonna eat it so that
you land on your feet not your neck nice
ouch that shit's gotta hurt
whoa thank yo lo it's [ __ ] sweet man
have you ever heard anyone say that
before I don't think so
what are those barrels thinking they're
taller than me every barrel think
they're better but they don't know my
y'all [ __ ] I don't know your low mood
either Oh does that is so stupid
Oh baby ah ah
game over huh what are you doing on top
of the Val's barrel sir all right press
I've said this many times before I'll
probably say it again cuz Santa Clara is
ugly gosh it's like that's what my brain
went to yes in your face Christina in
your face you can't stop me and your
ugliness no one told you what are you
what are you doing the [ __ ] is it what
is wrong with him what
what what what in them what what the
what what it god damn I hate you
[Laughter]
alright press we're gonna finish this
all off I know we can I know this
because I I don't know I know backflips
can we can you even make a double
backflip there's a backflip game and you
can't even make a double backflip what
kind of [ __ ] game asides and make a
double game without a backflip seriously
what the hell I could have programmed
this better with my tits now I don't
even have kids
okay can't program either but that
doesn't matter double backflip yes all
right I'm pretty good at this we can do
it what are you doing on top what are
you even going how am I supposed to know
yo lo yo you Joe a little too hard you
didn't look dick sucker
oh nice split bro nice double backflip
hmm
taste it taste it taste it taste it
man now I know how girls feel like that
hurts this dump is so difficult I don't
understand ah how can I fail on the Yolo
how can I fail I'm so disappointed god
[ __ ] damn it the back flips the back
flips you don't know what it's like you
don't know what it's like have you
played this you played it you know what
is the what I don't [ __ ] know these
days these days I am just very [ __ ]
sick of this [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
mother [ __ ] ass like a mother you
have to do this one
pure Yolo style I don't know I don't
know how the [ __ ] he does it but he does
it and that's all [ __ ] no no I [ __ ] up
you did don't diddly did not hey hey hey
we're gonna finish this I'm cereal
I'm not eating cereal I don't have it
eating cereal in a long time
makes me feel like I want to eat Sara
they look and I did that one oh that's
gotta hurt Sonny can I call you Sonny
you're not gonna make it
you're hopefully you're dead now hope
you die horribly
hope you all your friends forget about
you you dick god I hate you
this white white black clothes isn't
that a little offensive I think so I
think yes raise your hand I don't know I
just wanted you raise your hand okay and
you're dead you're cute okay all right
off with Yolo off with Yolo all right I
don't even know where to go here okay
I'm just gonna assume it's some [ __ ]
down here ouch Meddy jebra Yolo feed
that all right don't want to [ __ ] this
[ __ ] up okay okay okay okay
double back left a bangus campus what
the [ __ ] I got penetrated by three nice
meting idiot if it doesn't work the
first time don't [ __ ] try it ever
again remember that [ __ ] kids yeah
that's not gonna work
oh my god if that worked I would have to
work the more I play this game the more
I'm starting to regret my life god damn
it I think that's why the backflip
represents just [ __ ] self-hatred of
the past y'all oh hell yeah ha pi okay
last chance get it
[ __ ] got backflips it's worse than
twerking right now what the [ __ ] is that
are you you cannot be serious with me
all right
what just happened to the game GG is
[ __ ] PC Kraft
No I'm so good at this game seriously
yes yes no oh you [ __ ] was that okay
don't [ __ ] up slide down slide down
slide out hey didn't I George did I do
it what do I do now
okay this what that is not even a
backflip I'm done with this game never
playing this [ __ ] again I'll be right in
your eye like if you did I really
appreciate it describe become ready I'll
see the next one
[Music]